let's elaborate on something that Donald
Trump was talking about we got the story
from Forbes from a couple days ago
who wants to read that headline could
the US dollar collapse Donald Trump was
talking about this in his speech as they
are throwing everything at him to
destroy him possibly the only person who
can salvage the United States economy
and World standing Donald Trump they are
trying to stop
and if you look at how the bidens are
handling business dealings it makes a
lot of sense
if I had a bunch of money invested in
China I do not want the us to win right
a bet on China is a bet on China if
Donald Trump gets an office and the U.S
becomes great again and the dollar
becomes stronger and the economy
improves all of those foreign
investments take a hit
the incentive of these people if they're
investing in China
is to see the United States falter
but there are opportunities for the US's
Improvement to actually improve China
and vice versa that's where the value of
trade
it's very odd but at this point what are
we going to do about it like that's what
he said he's like you know we need to
stop this hell there's no mechanism for
us to stop any of this what particularly
stop what particularly like any of this
from happening like him you know them
stopping him him being indicted I I feel
like it's Domino's falling over
yeah I mean it is that's it it's a it's
a runaway train I don't know it's like a
commercial yeah there's an inertia in
motion right now but that's only going
to continue if no force is acted upon it
so we can change the momentum who's we
and how every human that has a camera on
the internet can can alter the fate of
humanity right now but but I mean that's
Ian a big statement with with not a
whole lot of substance I'm not sure what
and when half the people think Trump
should be in prison I don't see how what
you're you're encouraging does anything
I feel like sad because it does do stuff
but if you guys don't see it I mean I
can't make it no I I can see how like a
large you know if everybody with cameras
did their thing but you have to remember
that most people like the majority of
people don't even aren't even paying
attention to this right now right like
my friends who are taking their three
kids to school every day they're not
watching this they barely know what's
going on all they know is that he paid a
hooker and it's illegal like that's
literally all they know and so they
don't care they don't care and the media
it for the five minutes that they tune
in right before dinner is only going to
tell them one side of the story and our
message is really never getting out
unless it's to people who are heavily
invested in politics which isn't a ton
of people Stormy Daniels is a hooker
isn't she I mean technically I got
trouble on that for on Twitter I got
suspended for two weeks on Twitter for
calling her and is the exactly the word
that starts with a w and ends with an E
so I'm gonna be but I mean that as like
a scientific and academic term no
actually she is a woman who is paid to
have sex with men she sells her body for
money and she's very proud
for free is that what happened is that
why
I get apparently he like was like
flirting with her at a golf game I think
it was some had something to do with the
art of the deal and uh you know he
talked her down to a freebie let me try
it before I buy it otherwise I might
want to return it oh and she was just
like all right you get one freebie and
then he was like don't tell anybody
listen I think those type of women are
gross anyway but like she is extra gross
she was today she was talking on her
Twitter about people like like enter DMS
and stuff calling her like a
dumpster right like I'm trying not to be
whatever and she's like that is great
like I would rather be that than
arrested and like she like these people
are insane like she really thinks that
like her lifestyle well I just want to
point out it's funny how we can segue
from ladies and gentlemen
the country is collapsing I'm sorry the
dollar is failing I'm just so sick of
these your livelihood is at stake but
let's talk about this hooker well I mean
at least at least cash
I think a lot of this happened because
of feminism and women taking over and
and all those type of things and she is
just and more of that she's more of that
like women being empowered by their own
body right she is an extension of that
if we didn't have the the feminist
movement or even like the Civil Rights
the way they codified you know fit
certain things into law we wouldn't be
here right now that we would not be like
this and our society wouldn't certainly
wouldn't be hyper sexualized and over
sexualized and I wouldn't be worried
about my kids you know having to see
degenerate stuff in the middle of the
street though I don't care what it is
it's all degenerate and listen we
wouldn't have that much we wouldn't have
that much degeneracy if if men were men
and women were women and women stayed
home with kids and paid attention to
them and did the right thing and kept
them off Tick Tock and stuff like do
your job is this another repeal the 19th
thing listen I would I'm not saying to
repeal the 19th but I would happily give
up my right to vote if these liberal
women stopped voting 100 if that was the
deal you can ask would you give it up
forever yeah forever I mean I would give
up I don't even think women should
really be I mean I'm here because of the
necessity right like you know we need to
live in a two income household and I
kind of resent that like if I'm gonna do
a job yeah fine I'll be good at it I do
a little bit yeah you don't need a
limited to income I sold
I have to you just need a good
breadwinner okay but like
not everybody has the opportunity to get
a good Breadwinner okay don't sell
yourself short I'm not saying that but
but the point is it's like if I forced a
work which I in my situation am right
I'm gonna definitely be good at what I
do because I want to secure you know
things for my children but like I I
definitely resent that I resent that
we're in this type of culture where like
I have to work so it's it's annoys me
but I I blame really I I blame it on
women for a lot actually probably
everything that's the nature of uh
progressivism in this country is that
uh
what starts with tolerance becomes
acceptance becomes requirement
and celebration at first it was like
women want to work oh no we can't have
that and then eventually people were
like look if a woman wants to work just
let her work okay if she can do the job
she can do the job
then that was tolerance people people
tolerated women having jobs in some
places then it became outright
acceptance where all of a sudden you're
now seeing women being encouraged like
this is a normal thing now women should
work and then once all women were
working it's a requirement wouldn't have
to work now I was talking no longer a
choice I was doing a podcast today
talking to a buddy of mine and uh we
were talking about
um the way that oh I don't know I just
had a brain fart I totally lost what I
was going to say it happens to me all
the time like they're talking about
women yeah yeah you were taught women
okay so yeah I'm not sure where I was
going with that podcast I apologize
it's gone I might come back later but
something about repealing the 19th I
think is that I mean that's a great idea
no I'm just kidding I'm just kidding
it's always the men who are like don't
do it and the women who are like yes you
know he's like he's like I'm just
kidding I'm just kidding but are you but
are you really honestly honestly I'm I'm
a I'm a my personal opinion is is
democracy is not all that great
I take a more gender I ideological view
of voting and I think it shouldn't be
about men and women it should be about
your level of testosterone so if you
have a certain level of testosterone
above a number then you can vote yeah
you can only vote I mean I definitely
think that there should be some limits
to voting oh like I think that there
should be there are limits there are
limitations departments okay like
literacy requirements um I think that
there should be comprehension uh
requirements most people they read like
those um you know like the extra
measures on the balance and they don't
even know what they mean they have no
idea they're just checking boxes right
yeah not only that like you should be
invested somewhat in your community that
own property land I'm sorry like they're
it's not a freebie like everybody wants
everything handed to them in this life
like it's not no the idea that the right
to vote uh doesn't come along with some
kind of responsibility is a problem
everyone's a very very keen on talking
about their rights and that they have
the right to this and that
um rights come with responsibilities
there attached they're part of the right
you have responsibilities that are
literally ingrained in having the right
so if you have the right to own property
that means that you you are responsible
for that property you don't have the
right to take something else from
someone else you know you you have the
responsibility to get along with your
your you know your community and stuff
like that because you're free people
have the responsibility to behave in a
responsible manner in a way that works
with their community and stuff like that
but people are taking it too far like
they're taking the right to own property
as like the right like the right to own
it to work to own it right to someone
right to have property like that's
that's what I mean that's with
everything and that's why they can get
away with half the stuff right they're
like we are morally virtuous and
Superior and Trump's Hitler and so
therefore we could do whatever we want
and it's completely Justified because
it's what I want that's what my feelings
tell me to do yeah there's there's no
there's we've lost I don't I don't see
I've been saying this non-stop for years
but I do not see based on the paths that
we are on
any point at which in the near future
there's unification I don't either and
it's and and I feel like the more this
stuff happens the more it becomes clear
to other people what is happening people
love to complain and people love to to
poo poo the idea of any kind of civil
conflict and stuff like that but when
you tell them point to the off ramp
right so maybe it's not in the next two
three five ten years but tell me what
happens that makes the people that that
are on the left and the people on the
right agree to some way
I do have a vision of a future with a
non-violent resolution and that is
Donald Trump wins in 2024
he then immediately brings some better
people into doj a good AG indictments
are issued for corrupt Democrats the
people who pushed impeachment all these
other hoaxes are indicted tried and
charged the left loses their minds there
will be riotous moments but it won't
reach that level of total
destabilization we will then see some
degree of accountability and then from
there it will push out the corrupt left
and limit their ability to move forward
that along with people having kids
homeschooling them getting away from
cities is going to start Paving a future
out where the left becomes marginalized
I think right now the Divide is just too
great for that I mean I used to be like
that Arthur Brooks conservative Heart
Like Republican like oh we just need to
be nice to them and you know show our
empathy and get that way and I am not
that way now if you are on the side that
is weaponizing our justice system and
thinks it's okay and you are on the side
that are sexualizing my children you are
my enemy like literally my enemy well
I'm protecting my you're my enemy I
agree but what I'm saying is if Trump
wins in 2024 and immediately begin it
gets an AG who starts the indictment
process I think that will marginalize
the left
Trump's re-election in 2024 will strip
them of their abilities to do things
like they're doing now and it will
increasingly marginalize them their
propensity for sterilizing their kids
and aborting their own children combined
with conservatives having kids and
homeschooling them will mean that the
left will slowly be pushed out will get
smaller as time goes on imagine it like
this you got the left and the right the
left will get smaller as the right gets
bigger and then eventually they'll just
cease to exist and the future will just
become more populous pro-america it
starts with Donald Trump getting
reelected in 2024. yeah but do you think
that's a possibility oh yeah absolutely
I don't you don't think Trump can get
reelected I I think I love Trump and
that's who I want I want him more than I
want DeSantis or anybody else but I
think that the majority of it's about
it's ballot harvesting in ballot chasing
and yeah but we're not doing that we
don't have that right we don't have the
ground game like they do but who managed
to get it together but we do we're not
getting together the story is Orange
County traditionally conservative
introduces Universal male voting ballot
harvesting ghost Democrat Republicans
say hey wait a minute boom Republican
again you're asking a lot of the The
Establishment people that are already in
there think about it like how many
pressures do we know that's the only
person that's doing this you know what I
mean like we need like 70 more Scott
Presley without it it's way it's wicked
Bleak that's what I'm saying we got we
got at least 70 Scott pressler's
listening right now I hope okay Scott
pressler's I love you keep it up yeah
speaking of Scott Pressler there's a
really important election going on in
Wisconsin
is that what this is today are the polls
Wisconsin Supreme Court vote April 4th I
don't even know if the polls are still
open but they said make a noise about it
Scott I'm doing it on the show a lot of
people have been talking about making
noise about this election in Wisconsin
it pulls I don't know if they're open
all day I don't know but if you're able
to vote vote if you're in Wisconsin you
want to vote for your Supreme Court
Justice I think anybody listening who
wants to make sure we win just needs to
reach out to Scott Pressler and he's a
leader in this regard registering voters
leading the charge on ballot chasing and
where it's where it's legal ballot
harvesting and if you want to figure out
where to get started how to get started
he's your guy and he's so friendly like
he will answer anybody like he's the
nicest person to so yeah so I'm I I
don't know I'm fairly confident I think
if the election was held today Trump
would win
the polls say otherwise but I don't the
polls have always been wrong they're
wrong about everything I mean if there's
no
election Shenanigans right well maybe
but but here's the issue
Republicans need to get on their ground
game absolutely the activism the
knocking on doors the chasing and the
harvesting but right now
the economy is trash
people are angry and they're angry with
Joe Biden
and I was telling this story about how I
was at the casino last weekend and the
guy sitting next to me said he thought
the j6er should be executed
he also said Joe Biden is has destroyed
the dollar it's worthless and he keeps
sending our money overseas so this guy
clearly hates Joe Biden yeah would he
vote for Trump did you wouldn't vote
he's the kind of guy who abstains but
this is the kind of herb he's a he's a
Suburban uh liberal Indian guy who hates
Donald Trump absolutely hates Joe Biden
now but that's not going to help us like
guys like him are not helping anything
Democrats were able to win without
harvesting but it was also because
everything was locked down there was no
Sports no movies nothing to do and then
they went ballot harvesting they do not
have that if next year we get like h5n1
bird flu or whatever and everything's
locked down again maybe but Biden can't
do it twice the first time you fool me
you know fool me once shame on you fool
me twice shame on me
before me fool me a third time you're
not going to phone me a third time all
right George Bush there won't be there
won't be enthusiasm for him like people
will not turn out for him that's
probably I guess no one turned out for
Joe Biden no true 12 million new voters
turned out for Donald Trump what Joe
Biden got was not turnout but but
returns he got returns not turnout
returns and that was when a universal
Melon vote was sent to someone's house
it got returned because the Democrats
knew it doesn't matter what the
sentiment of the population is it
matters how many of these pieces of
paper in that box so I guarantee you you
got some guy knocking the door can I
what can I help you with something uh
have you filled out your ballot no okay
go don't come back look at I'm gonna
come back every day until I see you put
that in your mailbox okay fine whatever
here Biden get out of here what's in the
mailbox I have multiple ones sent to my
apartment and I I did absentee ballot
but that's the other thing too with with
the mail-in ballots when you separate
that outer envelope from the inner they
put them in two separate piles you're
never going to be able to match them up
again too so it's absolutely almost
impossible if it's mail-in balance to
tell us about eligible at once or not
I'm not even concerned about that
because I I I I think Democrats are that
crazy they get three balances of their
house they're filling them all out and
putting cents 100 sure maybe but I mean
it is a lot harder what I'm more
concerned with is just outright ballot
harvesting yeah like
you send a vote to every single person's
house the return rate's going to be
massive then you get very LAX signature
verification and that's all you need we
don't need to argue anything else so
Carrie Lakes moves to to check
signatures is brilliant because the
reality is a bunch of these ballots are
legitimate and got returned but probably
should be disqualified because they're
improperly filled out and can't be
securely verified
a lot of them are probably not good
which is why signature verification
exists right if this is the funny thing
they say that it's impossible for there
to be like oh there's no fraud okay Bill
Barr said there was fraud was there a
substantial amount that altered the
outcome of the election he said no the
issue is
with Carrie Lakes election there was
what 17 000 votes okay well now we got a
problem because we're talking about a
very small amount of errors and
malfeasance that could cause an election
to swing as it pertains to Donald Trump
in 2024 they're not going to have the
lockdowns they're not going to have the
political fervor they may try and
generate it with stories like this the
goal of this prosecution may be to get
Trump in the news and once again berate
regular people over the head and tell
them Trump's a criminal because they
want Trump in the news
they may backfire on them though because
they don't have covid this time to lock
people down take away what they love and
force them into a political world but
there are a lot of people and I know
this like from people in my own family
who were like Trump since he came down
the stairs they are really tired of
constant drama like they are they're
like listen if I I love him and I think
he's going to do a great job but if it
cost me all this and I don't feel that
way I want him to go in second term and
like burn everything I think he would be
on the biggest revenge tour ever and I
think it would be epic so I'm 100 there
for that but there are regular everyday
people that are tired that are tired of
all this I'm with you like I'm if he
wants to exact Justice legally then
whatever but don't just complain for 18
months about it don't be like the
radical left and that guy and that guy
like I was like nodding off like get I
get it do what you got to do when you
get there dude but you don't need to
convince us well he probably still needs
to convince some people give me a vision
of of goodness that's going to come out
of this and maybe you'll convince me
well it's hard to see a lot of visions
of goodness coming out of this I mean
they set the president what I think we
should do right now is I think that
McCarthy should start doing hearings on
um Hunter Biden and the laptop and Biden
himself and how he was corrupt right
like it well anything they can and then
I think all of the DA's anything at all
and all of the DA's should start looking
at every Democrat within their state to
do the same thing here's the deal right
like we they're already playing unfair
it's time for us to play unfair what
they did was they were like find me the
guy and I'll find you the crime do the
same thing now do it now thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time